[Música]
hay polémica en Uruguay después de la
captura de Alejandro astesiano jefe de
custodia del presidente uruguayo Luis la
calle Pau por un aparente fraude con
pasaportes astesiano fue detenido el 25
de septiembre acusado de dirigir una red
criminal que proveía partidas de
nacimiento falsas en las que decían que
ciudadanos rusos tenían padres uruguayos
lo que les permitía acceder entonces a
la ciudadanía de la República Oriental
del Uruguay de acuerdo con la fiscalía
uruguaya el funcionario se reunía con
sus conspiradores en la torre ejecutiva
que es la sede de el presidente de la
presidencia o El Ejecutivo en Uruguay la
investigación indica que son cerca de 20
los casos de ciudadanos rusos con
pasaportes obtenidos por esta vía ilegal
pero podría haber muchos más el
presidente Luis la calle pop negó tener
cualquier tipo de conocimiento sobre
este caso Uruguay que es tal vez una de
las democracias más destacadas de la
región un país que para el resto de
América Latina es un ejemplo de
transparencia está cayendo en las gala
Las garras de la corrupción es una
pregunta que surge a raíz de este caso y
a raíz de otro caso que ha habido unas
meses atrás porque ya ha habido dos
casos de escándalos grandes de grandes
proporciones de corrupción en ese país
suramericano qué tanto afecta Esto
entonces a la institucionalidad de
Uruguay que tanto afecta esto al
gobierno del presidente de la calle lo
vamos a analizar entonces en el debate
de France 24 para conversar sobre este
tema hemos invitado a Nicolás centurión
Él es director del colectivo periferia
también es analista del centro
latinoamericano de análisis estratégico
clave también está con nosotros desde la
ciudad de Montevideo Juan Miguel
carceolo carsolio Él es periodista de
radio sarandí también ustedes pueden ser
parte de esta conversación a través de
las redes sociales ustedes ya saben que
pueden dejar todas sus preguntas y
comentarios a través de Twitter de
Facebook y de Instagram nos encuentran
como arroba el debate guión bajo f2 4
arroba santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f24 no olviden que todos los
contenidos de este programa también
están disponibles en diferentes
plataformas de podcast no se encuentran
en Apple podcast en Spotify deezer y
tuning
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Nicolás en la ciudad de Montevideo
Nicolás Gracias por acompañarnos hoy en
el programa Punto de partida y hago esta
pregunta estando fuera de las fronteras
uruguayas y tal vez lo que uno piensa
leer estos casos de corrupción y sobre
todo este caso de los pasaportes
uruguayos es que tal vez Uruguay es un
no es un país tan transparente como se
percibe desde afuera y que la corrupción
está llegando incluso a altas esferas
del gobierno
Sí bueno Santiago primero antes que nada
Muchas gracias por la invitación y
saludo a Juan también bueno Uruguay
tiene la autopercepción y también es una
percepción una fama que se ha ganado a
lo largo del tiempo hacer como la suiza
a América una isla y una excepción en
Latinoamérica y el Caribe pero
Generalmente no no están así y bueno
estos casos como el caso abastesiano el
caso marcet habla Que obviamente en
Uruguay existe la corrupción y existe
también todo un entramado que bueno las
organizaciones
internacionales de delito también
permean aquí en Uruguay no por ejemplo
en un libro que salió recientemente aquí
que se llama Los protectores del capital
de un sociólogo Gabriel tenemón Que
plantea bueno desde hace décadas por lo
menos tres cuatro décadas que Uruguay es
un lugar muy apetecible para el lado de
activos Y eso implica obviamente mucho
contacto con el narcotráfico Así que
esto también
este caso de esta organización que
implica rusos y en la torre ejecutiva
como bien planteabas al inicio muestra
que Uruguay no está exento de todos
estos problemas Lamentablemente ahora le
doy la palabra Juan Miguel también hay
en Montevideo Bienvenido al programa
Juan Miguel la misma pregunta como Punto
de partida es esta percepción
simplemente eso una percepción de que
Uruguay es un país muy transparente en
la región latinoamericana pero la
corrupción allí También llega hasta
altas esferas del gobierno
hay que dar hasta donde también este
caso termina
llegando en cuanto a lo que es el hilo
que la fiscalía comenzó a seguir ahora
no y cuál es el involucramiento real que
tienen esas altas esferas porque esto
ocurría en la torre ejecutiva pero por
personas que si eran de confianza
extrema para el presidente y por eso es
un golpe duro tal vez a la imagen el más
duro en lo que va del gobierno pero
también hay que ver lo que es el propio
accionar de la fiscalía que
se puede detener en la propia residencia
presidencial Y entonces ahí ver cuáles
son los niveles en los que hoy en el
parlamento uruguayo se está debatiendo
el tema porque hay repercusiones en la
justicia a nivel político y por supuesto
a nivel internacional por eso estamos
acá en contacto con todos ustedes y
aprovecho para saludar a Nicolás también
comparte lo que decía al principio
respecto a que a veces hay una
percepción que tiene que ver con niveles
de corrupción que tal vez son menores y
que en otros países pero que para nada
es impermeable
la institucionalidad uruguaya a la
corrupción y de hecho en una lógica
argumental que a veces es un poco
infantil pero que se repite mucho en
estos casos empiezan a aparecer hechos
del pasado que se señalan como similares
donde hay circunstancias y personas y
nombres que se repiten y que salpican al
actuales directores del ministerio
interior de lo que es la cúpula policial
en nuestro país director de migraciones
director de identificación civil claro
director de claro desde lo que es
también la el propio Instituto Nacional
de rehabilitaciones que trata con los
presos que terminan por ahora en un
círculo cercano astesiano al Custodio de
la calle que es el principal involucrado
y que por ahí también me parece que hay
que ver cuáles son las repercusiones que
a nivel de la justicia llega a ver por
este tema con otras personas integrantes
del gobierno por ahora que eran un nivel
sí de una de un grupo delictivo que
funcionaba en las narices del presidente
eso
tres pisos para abajo de donde él
trabaja
ahí tienen ustedes las opiniones de los
dos invitados Yo quiero aclarar que la
producción de el programa El Debate de
France 24 intentó contactar a alguien
del gobierno uruguayo o alguien cercano
a este caso a esta investigación para
conocer más detalles y para conocer
también la versión del gobierno para
hacer aquí un balance en cuanto a la
información y al análisis del caso y fue
imposible contactar a alguien para que
estuviera presente en este el programa
sin embargo con Nicolás y Juan Miguel
pues vamos a hacer el análisis de la
situación a conocer en detalle que lo
que está pasando allí en Uruguay sobre
este caso tan particular Juan Miguel
continuo con usted para hacer la ronda a
la inversa y usted mismo nos dice que
esto está empezando a salpicar otras
instancias del gobierno estaríamos en la
punta del iceberg de un gran caso de
corrupción que envuelve diferentes áreas
del gobierno de la calle y diferentes
sectores de la de los sectores políticos
uruguayos qué piensa usted
a esta hora mientras hablamos nosotros
en el parlamento empezaron a aparecer y
los últimos días en la prensa también
algunos elementos que exceden al
gobierno pero por ahora el asunto está
limitado a lo que era el Custodio del
presidente que además es un Custodio que
de alguna manera heredó de su padre ex
presidente y que cuando fue Custodio de
su padre trabajaba en ese mismo equipo
con todas estas personas que te mencioné
Por eso digo que ahí hay una trama que
hay que ver hasta dónde llega y sin duda
que hay un elemento que tiene que ver
con la participación de esta esta
delincuencia organizada del exterior en
este caso rusa involucrada en el asunto
y que también pone en riesgo el
prestigio del propio pasaporte uruguayo
que vos decías al principio es algo que
a nivel continental era muy valorado y
quedaba muchas garantías por eso también
era muy apetecible de repente para para
algunos y queda demostrado que por por
los hechos que hoy se están investigando
por parte de la justicia y por también
algunos que se están revelando en el
parlamento de de gobiernos anteriores
que no era tan
infranqueable como se pensaba esa
identificación uruguaya claro además Hay
que decir que si hay una ciudadanía
difícil de obtener para un extranjero es
justamente la ciudadanía uruguaya para
una persona que reciba en ese país
durante mucho tiempo y paga impuestos no
es garantía de obtener la ciudadanía
uruguaya es uno de los pasaportes más
difíciles de obtener si se compara con
otras nacionalidades y ahí también
extraña mucho que estas personas de un
momento a otro sin tener ni siquiera
conocimiento del idioma español tenían
esta este pasaporte uruguayo en
condiciones pues mucho más fáciles de lo
normal pasó a darle la palabra a Nicolás
a preguntarle Entonces el hermetismo que
ha habido en torno a este caso la
producción de este programa tuvo muchas
dificultades para encontrarlos a ustedes
dos para acceder a personas en Uruguay
que quisieran sobre el caso que dieran
su perspectiva su punto de vista desde
el gobierno es muy poco lo que dicen hay
mucho hermetismo desde el gobierno hay
miedo en el gobierno de la calle que
esto destape una olla y en de alguna
forma salpique funcionarios muy cercanos
al presidente
Sí yo creo que hubo digamos dos
movimientos o dos etapas en cuanto a la
comunicación del gobierno primero que
fue el presidente que en seguía salió a
hacer una conferencia de prensa y
aclarar los tantos Digamos como se dice
acá y los hechos como pasaron el tema
que un Pilar fundamental que tenía este
gobierno que ya carece de él que es
justamente el tema de la comunicación el
tema del presidente salir a la cara el
tema de que tiene muchas veces se lo
califica acá como agencia de publicidad
en cuanto a que cada paso que se da a
cada acción cada política cada gestión
está muy bien pensada y muy bien
planificada Ahora la conferencia del
propio presidente mostró un montón de
contra no por ejemplo cuando el
presidente decía que él desconocía las
anotaciones y los antecedentes de
astesiano cuando resultó ser que el
propio Garcés que es el secretario
inteligente
a su vez que un dirigente del interior
de Rivera le había avisado el fallecido
ministro ex ministro del interior Jorge
Larrañaga para que le avisara al
presidente a su vez también diciendo que
por ejemplo solo lo afectaba a su
familia y a él y no al país y la verdad
que es algo que que afecta Como por
ejemplo Ahora nos están convocando para
esta entrevista porque realmente ha
llegado a niveles internacionales no
Entonces esto como decía Bueno también
Juan hay una cuestión que hay que
investigar y ver porque esto se remonta
bastante tiempo atrás el periodista
Antonio Lara lanzó una información hace
recientemente más o menos una hora que
en 1993
alexay fredori chef Perdón en que no soy
bueno con el ruso que fue un Traficante
de armas y estuvo preso tenía un
pasaporte uruguayo Entonces esto digamos
refleja que puede haber
unos antecedentes de décadas importancia
que ver toda la gente que está
involucrada en esto sí Sí apenas estamos
conociendo temas conociendo aspectos del
caso Juan Miguel su impresión ha habido
hermetismo se está manejando esto dentro
de un secretismo por parte del Estado y
de las autoridades antes de meternos ya
en el caso como tal ahí la creo que que
la palabra secretismo le queda un poco
grande la situación Porque el presidente
dio la cara era una conferencia en la
que cometió errores y dijo
o manejo de información equivocada de
hecho uno de los elementos fuertes que
eran esa conferencia maneja para
defender la decisión de haber contado
con anestesiano en su equipo de
seguridad personal era el hombre que lo
acompañaba con su familia de vacaciones
por ejemplo la semana anterior por lo
tanto es un golpe personal pero también
hay un golpe político evidente una
repercusión internacional que no lo
ayuda nada y en esa primera semana en la
calle dio la cara varias veces pero hubo
contradicciones porque resultaba que sí
había antecedentes y que ahí hay otra
desprolijidad es lo que es la el manejo
de la información por parte del
Ministerio del interior y la lógica por
la cual
Debería ser imposible que desaparezca
información sobre estesiano que cuando
el presidente la pidió en su legajo no
estaba entonces ahí se abre otra línea
de investigación también respecto a lo
que es el Ministerio interior una
cancillería que ya se había vivido esto
muy afectada también por el episodio de
Merced que mencionaban al principio no
Sebastián marcet un hombre apuntado
desde Colombia como uno de los
referentes ya no del tráfico sino
también de los delitos como homicidios
vinculados al narcotráfico a nivel
internacional ese caso que hizo tuvo
también mucha repercusión del fiscal
paraguayo asesinado en Colombia el
propio presidente colombiano lo señala
como el responsable y su obtención de un
pasaporte Express como se le llamó acá
estando retenido en los emiratos también
Obviamente que generó mucha Escocia y
dudas respecto a cómo funcionan esas
cosas en Uruguay Me parece que de todas
maneras el manejo de la información de
parte del gobierno hoy por ejemplo están
los el ministro de interior pero también
el prosecretario de la presidencia dando
explicaciones en el parlamento una
concurrencia la del secretario que no
era obligatoria legalmente pero que se
decida ayer hacer creo que que hay un
cambio también allí en la lógica de
Bueno hasta acá dimos la cara con lo que
pasó ahora vamos a esperar que la
justicia actúe y Determine Cuáles son
las responsabilidades ahí también de
parte de la fiscal ha habido mucho
hermetismo en elegir noll a hacer de
esto un circo mediático sino dedicarse a
la causa y hablar en el juzgado ella
mismo dijo a veces los fiscales habla
mucho en la prensa y y hablan pocos los
juzgados Bueno ella ha decidido hablar
en el juzgado Juan Miguel vuelvo a hacer
la ronda la inversa continuó con usted
armemos este rompecabezas para las
personas que estamos fuera de Uruguay no
y no conocemos bien a los personajes de
esta historia comerciamos por
se engendro artesiano investigado más de
20 veces en las últimas dos décadas
entre ellas por múltiples fraudes muchas
acusaciones y la investigación pues ha
tenido diferentes deficiencias y no a no
ha llegado a una conclusión
digamos grande sobre lo que lo que ha
realizado este señor en estas
acusaciones no ha habido O sea no ha ido
a la cárcelles a lo que quiero decir
pero es una persona muy cercana al
presidente qué más se puede decir de
este personaje que Aparentemente estaría
siendo la cabeza de esta organización
Bueno si me permitís un detalle porque
es uno de los elementos centrales en
cuanto a los errores que al principio
comete el presidente esos antecedentes
sí existían y él había estado preso
estuvo preso en el año 2014 por un
delito continuado de estafa y además
estuvo procesado condenado por un delito
de estafa en el año 2012 es decir que sí
tenía antecedentes donde la justicia le
había encontrado una responsabilidad el
presidente supuestamente de esos
antecedentes no haya sido informado si
del resto de las anotaciones que también
acá en Uruguay decimos a veces en
Uruguay nos conocemos todos había mucha
gente que podía tener idea de quién era
astesiano Y de esa serie de situaciones
circunstancias que tampoco en ningún
caso eran investigaciones delito deberán
escala no eran más bien cuestiones de
estafa menores pero no era un hombre
evidentemente que pudiera decir que
había tenido una trayectoria
transparente por lo menos en los últimos
20 años desde la perspectiva de lo que
es la policía y las propias
investigaciones de la justicia que
habían concluido que había cometido
delitos entonces ahí también surge un
poco la duda de Quiénes son los
contactos que él utilizaba para sacar
beneficios de esta que sí se transforma
en una maniobra mucho más importante
donde hasta ahora hay 20 pasaportes
involucrados pero la fiscal en las pocas
cosas que dijo habló de que pueden ser
miles los pasaportes ese es otro de que
me parece importante señalar y hasta
dónde llevaba la organización si
realmente astesiano se manejaba con la
gente que conocía desde hace mucho
tiempo y había logrado ocupar cargos de
poder o si hay una responsabilidad
política de quienes los va a dar una
responsabilidad ante la justicia de
quienes lo designaron esos cargos la
responsabilidad política está después
hay que ver hasta dónde también puede
haber una responsabilidad eventualmente
penal que ahí sí creo que la corrupción
estaría llegando a los niveles más altos
del gobierno Ahora hay una coincidencia
del lugar donde en algún momento se
reunieron hay evidentemente una cercanía
por la confianza que tenía el presidente
en esta persona pero no está demostrado
que los principales dirigentes políticos
estuvieran involucrado o sacaran algún
rédito de estas maniobras que ahora sí
parecen ser de otra escala Incluso hoy
en lo que se manejaba el parlamento se
hablaba de unos rusos que pedían que en
el gobierno de Mujica se les apurara la
la el pasaporte y lo que ocurría ahí es
que
En aquel momento esos nombres coincide
con los que uno está involucrado en el
caso es decir hay que ver hasta donde
llega el hilo de esa madeja sí esto
apenas está comenzando este caso apenas
se ha destapado la olla de lo que está
sucediendo allí Nicolás ahora vemos un
vistazo a la otra cara de la moneda
estos ciudadanos rusos Quiénes son Qué
se sabe de ellos qué propósitos tenían
con estos pasaportes uruguayos
simplemente recibir en Uruguay facilitar
su trámite o son personas que ni
siquiera Residen en la República
Oriental y están usando este pasaporte
para moverse en diferentes países
alrededor del mundo Qué información hay
sobre esto
bueno de la información que hasta el
momento se sabe de estos rusos es que
ingresaron en el año 2021 precisamente
el 19 de abril a su vez es una solicitud
que hubo de 43 personas que ingresarán
al país recordemos que en esa época
estamos en pandemia y fue autorizado por
el propio secretario de Presidencia
Álvaro Delgado No Entonces eso también
es una punta a investigar de si fue
solamente una firma administrativa si
estaba al tanto de Por qué dio el
ingreso esas 43 personas que repito
dentro de ellas están estos rusos
estamos hablando de andrey
ballerinevich castanov que es de 55 años
y figura como abogado y a su vez olesia
ciumelia de 40 años que se presenta como
economista estos dos rusos que a su vez
formaban parte de de digamos el núcleo
más cercano de astesiano para hacer
Estas actividades
se casaron
en la ciudad fronteriza con Brasil del
Chuy en un supermercado
casados por el alcalde de esa localidad
que pertenece al partido Colorado esto
empieza a tomar algunos ribetes más
sospechosos No porque se casan justo acá
al llegar al Uruguay y a su vez prometen
inversiones como casinos hoteles o
shoppings y bueno esas
esas inversiones todavía no llegaron y
se concretaron pero también se averiguó
que casta nom formó parte fue un alto
funcionario del ministerio ruso entonces
ahí se empieza a
entretejer algunas cosas justo la esposa
del alcalde que los casa es
prima del dueño del supermercado donde
se casaron no sé si me explicó en esa
trama entonces bueno se sigue
averiguando hay otro ruso también que
Que bueno que facilitaba
todas estas cuestiones por Facebook que
tenían un grupo incluso de 8000 personas
destapando y ahí engancho también y su
Rayo lo que decía Juan sobre que un
hackeo hace un tiempo en la dirección
nacional se identificación que fueron 84
mil pasaportes que se fue agraron y eso
es lo que planteó un momento la fiscal
fosati de que también puede ser una
línea de investigación que eso podría
destapar muchísimos casos y habría que
investigar todos esos pasaportes y las
consecuencias internacionales que eso
podría traer Nicolás leyendo algunos
medios uruguayos Tal parece que las
autoridades de este país estaban muy
bien informadas sobre los problemas
relacionados con esta forma de otorgar
esta ciudadanía
a diferentes ciudadanos extranjeros y el
reclamo que se hace desde algunos medios
es que se ignoraron todas los las
alertas que esto despertó las
irregularidades en los procesos
Porque eran denuncias que venían siendo
hechas desde hace por lo menos dos años
qué fue lo que pasó ahora que desta este
escándalo dos años después si las
denuncias ya venían siendo hechas con
tanta anterioridad
sí ocurrió paralelamente dos sucesos que
hicieron como que esto saliera a la luz
que fue también una denuncia desde el
exterior del consulado
uruguayo en México por muchas
solicitudes de rusos que querían venir a
Uruguay no Y eso llamó un poco la
atención por la cantidad y a su vez
también muchos rusos que que ingresaban
a pedir el pasaporte no y bueno la
demanda enorme que había eso despertó la
la atención de la de la gente de los
funcionarios de identificación civil que
a su vez en un momento empezaron a ver
que los pasaportes por ejemplo se dieron
cuenta que el
QR que aparece el código QR en el
pasaporte que tiene que enviar a un
sitio público un sitio público web no
mandaba a ningún lado y empezaron a ver
esas irregularidades la cuestión es que
el pasaporte en este caso aparecía
como legal que no era Digamos trucho
como se viene diciendo no eran falsos
pero aquí se hacía este mecanismo de
poner algún pariente Ya fallecido lo que
fuere que sea uruguayo para que los
rusos puedan venir estas dos cosas no la
gran demanda desde el exterior y la gran
demanda y a su vez irregularidades en
algunos pasaportes fue lo que despertó
acá la atención de la gente la
identificación civil claro y esto
completamente descarta porque también
hay que decir que hay una pequeña
comunidad de rusos en Uruguay que han
llegado a lo largo de los años
hay antecedentes de llegada de
ciudadanos rusos desde principios del
siglo pasado a la República Oriental
Pero entonces queda descartado que estas
personas no tienen ningún tipo de
relación con descendientes de estos
migrantes que han llegado a lo largo de
los años a la República Oriental Juan
Miguel continuó con usted para
preguntarle por la presión y el peso que
le está recayendo en este momento al
gobierno de la calle Pou esto Qué
significa para el gobierno del
presidente que venía con más o menos
digamos una buena popularidad a raíz del
manejo que le dio a la pandemia del Kobe
19 había un buen
una buena organización de la economía
para justamente para abrir otra vez el
país después de la de los confinamientos
y el país iba marchando o va marchando
relativamente bien pero esto Entonces
qué tanta presión ejerce sobre el
ejecutivo
Y todavía sin conocer información
respecto a la encuesta permanente que ya
sean de la gestión de la evolución de la
gestión del presidente si nos
encontramos claramente ante decía yo más
temprano El golpe más duro porque fueron
como dos golpes no por el lado de lo
personal pero también por el lado de lo
político y también porque era un hombre
que se había mostrado muy firme en la
comunicación y en esto cometió estos
errores que comentábamos antes y que
hacen También a por qué ahora el caso
toma esta trascendencia porque sí había
habido advertencias en la prensa en
radio sarandí por ejemplo lo informamos
pero también la diaria en su momento y
otros medios uruguayos se habían
destacado que existía toda esta
información Respecto a los antecedentes
de artesianos la calle del primer día
dice que lo reconoce el segundo día dice
que sí el primer día dice que no va a
tomar otras medidas respecto a
eventuales filtros para quienes integran
esos equipos tan cercanos de su custodia
que además tienen la responsabilidad no
sólo de custodiarlo sino por ejemplo a
los presidentes que llegan del
extranjero Entonces al segundo día se
vuelve a destacar que buena parte de su
equipo también tenía anotaciones y la
calle decide remover a 10 funcionarios
de ese lugar Entonces hubo un cambio
también ahí en la estrategia y un
reconocimiento que había habido un error
en la gente que se había elegido para su
confianza habrá que ver hasta dónde
ahora a nivel de la justicia llega esa
piola que también se va para el exterior
Porque estos mismos rusos hacían algo
parecido en Bulgaria allá se hablaba del
pasaporte europeo barato parece que
encontraron la sucursal para hacerlo acá
en Latinoamérica con el pasaporte
uruguayo por ese valor que tenía en
aquel momento el pasaporte de búlgaros
para la Unión Europea hoy el pasaporte
uruguayo para latinoamérica Me parece
que también parte de lo que termine
siendo la determinación o hasta dónde
pueda llegar la justicia en la
investigación va a ser decisivo respecto
al impacto que pueda tener políticamente
en el presidente en el presidente de la
calle Juan hay hipótesis sobre lo que
estaban estos rusos o el fin que tenían
con estos pasaportes porque entendemos
también la coyuntura por la que está
atravesando Rusia en este momento a raíz
de el conflicto con Ucrania muchos
ciudadanos están dejando el país para
evitarse reclutados para las filas del
ejército otro simplemente pues quieren
salir porque el país no va bien
económicamente por las sanciones y esto
empieza a mover estos
mercados clandestinos de ciudadanías y
tráficos de pasaportes no solamente en
Uruguay usted ya cita el caso búlgaro
también hay evidencias hay hipótesis que
relacionen que tal vez Estas personas no
iban a cometer ningún tipo de crímenes
simplemente están buscando una forma de
poderse mover hacia otros países y
escapar de Rusia
más bien Parece ser una organización que
por un lado hacía negocio con los
propios pasaportes y por otro lado habrá
que ver que otras cosas hacían esos
contactos cuando obtenían los pasaportes
uruguayos no quién y para qué me parece
que es algo que todavía está por verse
Es cierto que esta causa viene desde
antes de que empezara la guerra no en
2020 está vinculado a lo que decía
Nicolás que ocurrió en México que
aparecieran nuevos elementos él hablaba
de que aparecían hijos de personas
fallecidas pero resulta que un anciano
que vivía un Residencial le aparece un
hijo Ruso y no entiende qué pasa y se
transforma a su vez es pintoresco pero a
su vez habla de cómo estaba funcionando
la organización en un testigo clave para
entender cuál es la trama y cuál es la
forma en la cual estos rusos obtenían un
pasaporte legal a partir de una
ciudadanía falsa lo que era falso era
que no eran ciudadanos uruguayas no
podían obtener la ciudadanía de padres
que no eran sus padres y esa es la forma
en la que la la y por eso después el
pasaporte era legal como bien apuntada
también Nicolás Nicolás Juan Miguel me
aparto un poco de este caso en
específico y pongo sobre la mesa dos
temas que me llama la atención para
analizar del caso uruguayo en específico
y es la transparencia de este país que
ya lo decíamos a nivel internacional es
un país siempre muy bien rankeado y el
otro tema es el crimen transnacional qué
tal parece que Uruguay no es ajeno a
este tipo de de actividades Comencemos
por la transparencia la sensación que
tienen ustedes allí es de individualidad
de las instituciones que funcionan
correctamente que el país es
transparente en sus gastos en su forma
de administrarse por lo menos eso es lo
que vemos desde afuera sobre todo lo
vemos desde países sumamente corruptos
como puede ser Argentina o Colombia que
es donde está la sede France 24 que
bueno es un país que ha estado
involucrado en diferentes casos de
corrupción no sólo a nivel nacional sino
internacional caso odebrecht por ejemplo
la percepción de transparencias y en
Uruguay qué tan eficiente es el gobierno
la institucionalidad para garantizar
esta transparencia que ahora queda en
entredicho Nicolás
Sí bueno a ver las sensaciones son
ambiguas porque vos también nombraste
recién a odebrecht y están involucrados
por ejemplo en esta trama la esposa del
actual ministro de cultura la contadora
Maya sikurell que está involucrada con
el tema de lavado de activos que aquí
quizás no se destapó la trama odebrecht
porque no no hubo construcciones de
dicha empresa Pero sí Uruguay fungió
como mecanismo de lavado eso creo que la
percepción que hay de Uruguay es por un
tema también de escala de cuestión que
no ha habido grandes casos de corrupción
o tampoco gravita tanto a nivel
internacional como para que esa noticia
Lamentablemente Ahora sí está haciendo
noticia por esto por el otro lado si hay
una institucionalidad en cuanto es
transparente por ejemplo
el presidente bueno astesiano fue
detenido en la residencia presidencial
eso es un punto positivo por el otro
lado después se sabe que se le había y
el 24 horas antes ya lo sabía y pudo
borrar mensajes que lo Podrían haber
comprometido mucho más
si Uruguay tiene mecanismos de control
en este caso que la fiscal hasta el
momento pueda investigar y a su vez no
haya recibido amenazas por ejemplo lo
que sea demuestra que existe la
separación de poderes y que se pueda
llegar a buen Puerto con esta
investigación que creo que va a ser lo
más favorable no yo creo que a nivel
institucional no sólo de gobierno es un
buen momento para revisar un montón de
cosas y si esto llega un buen Puerto que
caigan las personas que tengan que caer
involucradas desde las décadas que hayan
sido esto eso sería muy favorable Y eso
mejorarían parte la imagen del país que
quedó dañada por este caso y algunos más
y Juan Miguel le preguntó Porque ya me
quedan pocos minutos para finalizar el
programa del crimen transnacional el
narcotráfico que es Tal vez un problema
vertical para todos los países de
América Latina Pero uno sentía que tal
vez Uruguay no estaba tan permeado por
esta problemática como si lo está
Argentina como lo está Colombia como lo
está Ecuador y Venezuela
qué tan complicado es el tema allí
porque también leyendo algunos informes
sobre el tema dice que el gobierno
uruguayo ha reconocido que tienen
problemas en su capacidad para poder
frenar justamente el narcotráfico
transfronterizo con Brasil y con
Argentina
bueno las cosas que en los últimos años
se veían en Latinoamérica
de a poco empezaron a llegar a Uruguay y
estaba claro que el crimen organizado no
se iba a detener por las fronteras
porque la uruguaya están permeable como
la del resto de los países y cuando
encontró sobre todo en Uruguay un camino
de tránsito de drogas hacia el exterior
bueno evidentemente que no es por el
mercado uruguayo que se vuelve tan
atractiva esta Plaza como ocurre también
en el caso del lavado de activos pero
sobre todo en lo que son las
repercusiones en materia de seguridad
pública en Uruguay hasta hace unos años
no había homicidios por encargo y mucho
menos estábamos acostumbrados a ver
gente baleada
de a dos de a tres
mutilados todas cosas que se veían en
otros países y queda poquito una tras
otra fueron llegando a Uruguay porque
evidentemente que hubo una penetración
que se fue dando tal vez en las últimas
dos décadas de la parte más violenta del
narcotráfico sobre todo de
organizaciones que tienen contactos
desde Brasil y que ya Incluso en la
frontera el Ministerio del interior
reculó tomando la decisión de no
instalar allí a la guardia republicana
que es la policía digamos de
confrontación más fuerte que tiene no
instalarla allí con con una sede
permanente por temor a lo que podía
ocurrir con el comando sur de Brasil
entonces evidentemente que hay cada vez
más cercanía incluso de algunas
organizaciones uruguayas que no son tal
vez grandes organizaciones a nivel
continental pero que empiezan a generar
esos vínculos y sobre todo lo que yo
constato y lo que me parece más
perjudicial para la sociedad como pasa a
nivel de latinoamérica es el crimen
asociado a esto no la violencia los
homicidios de gente que tiene que ver y
que no tiene nada que ver y de muchas
muchas plazas de las cárceles ocupadas
por el tráfico y el micro tráfico en
algunos casos y los grandes contenedores
de droga que siguen saliendo hacia los
países consumidores no que en general
los grandes negocios están en el norte
claro esto es una realidad no solamente
en Uruguay sino en la mayoría de los
países de América Latina me quedan ya un
par de minutos para finalizar el
programa hagamos entonces las
conclusiones de lo que viene para este
caso de lo que viene para Uruguay ahora
que hemos despejado cómo está el
panorama de la seguridad del crimen
transnacional y de la transparencia de
este país y que hemos visto también un
poco más en detalle este caso en
particular comienzo con Nicolás su
conclusión de lo que puede venir para
las próximas semanas los próximos meses
presione el gobierno presiones las
autoridades para poder desarrollar este
caso y bueno Qué puede pasar
Sí primeramente el Gobierno ya tenía
abierto varios frentes de conflicto se
puede hablar por ejemplo de la Reforma
de la seguridad social el tema de la
reforma educativa también con respecto
al tema de las Ollas populares que yo
estaba generando por ejemplo en estas
últimas dos distintas marchas una en
Torre ejecutiva otra también en el
centro de Montevideo que estaban
movilizando a miles de personas y a su
vez se le suma esto el caso marcet y el
caso artesiano que tiene que ver con
pasaportes y bueno hace perder la
credibilidad que tenía el gobierno como
repito en materia comunicativa estaba
haciendo muy Sólido y la cantidad de
contradicciones que expuso el presidente
en esa conferencia de prensa hacen que
que pierda eso y a su vez el tema de
tener una asociación para delinquir
dentro de la propia Torre ejecutiva más
allá si el presidente tenía implicancias
o no más allá a qué altas esferas eso
pero a la mitad del gobierno eso le
genera más más conflictos de los que ya
tenía y bueno también vamos a ver si eso
repercute en la próxima campaña
electoral Miguel rápidamente me quedan
30 segundos para finalizar el programa
su conclusión
bueno justo perdimos la conexión con
Juan Miguel justo al final del programa
para su conclusión a los dos les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
en el programa No fue fácil conseguirlos
para que dieran su análisis aquí para la
audiencia de France 24 les agradezco por
haber estado con nosotros gracias por su
sintonía y En nombre del equipo técnico
Les agradecemos que hayan estado con
nosotros la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Laura garzón y la
producción de invitados a cargo de Tania
Herrera sigan con Franz 24
[Música]